[Music]
kevin is in buffalo new york hey kevin
how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
good so i just got a question about life
insurance so
before i really listen to you so my i'm
an electrician by trade and i work
quite a bit i'm only 23 years old i work
and i also have some family friends who
do a lot of
property management so i work on the
side for them as well good
so um yeah like i said i'm 23 currently
i'm making about
17 1800 a week after taxes including the
part-time side
jobs um so my life insurance policy
i got two years ago before i listened to
you is whole life
um it's a thirteen thousand dollar a
year premium
but it's a twenty pay one million dollar
death benefit
covers long-term care um
and obviously has a cash value but then
when i started hearing you say
um to go term instead invest the
difference
it's now in my head about what i should
do
so i don't know what i should do okay
well um number one you're 23 you don't
need to worry about long-term care
insurance
that's asinine okay that they sold a 23
year old a long-term care insurance
policy
absolutely asinine but that's what these
people do
and so the uh the second thing is this
13 000 dollars
for a million dollars on a 23 year old
did i get that right yeah um but i guess
have you priced term insurance on a 23
year old
no i have but like the only reason i
liked it
is no no no no i wouldn't ask him why
you like it i said have you
priced a million dollars on a 23 year
old term life insurance with zander
insurance
like 30 40 yeah
yeah like three four hundred bucks a
year yeah
yeah okay which means that uh
twelve thousand
almost thirteen thousand dollars is
going into a savings account inside that
policy
did you notice how much your savings
account your cash value build up is for
the first year
did you notice that it was zero yes
do you not feel screwed because you were
that's why i'm saying well i'm serious
you got you put you put 12
600 in a savings account and the balance
is
zero this is bad math
this is bad math and you're gonna do it
again next year
please don't tell me there's any reason
in your brain that thinks this is a good
idea
no i mean no get rid of this crap are
you married today no i'm single
uh we'll just cancel it today okay
today if you want to get some insurance
you don't need a million dollars on you
to start with because you don't you're
not leaving anybody behind that's gonna
not eat because you don't do electrician
stuff you you know
you know you might need a little bit to
bury you so your mom and dad don't have
to pay for it
do you have a bunch of debt zero
good how much money you have in savings
um well i started working at 19 i have
195
000 in a mutual fund good for you i
think your parents will be able to bury
you
you don't okay you don't need life
insurance son
at all okay at all okay and now when
you're married and have a couple kids
and your wife is counting on you
to make 90 000 a year to feed her and
those kids
yeah now maybe we'll pick up a million
dollars at that point
and buy you a 15 or a 20-year level term
policy for three or four hundred dollars
a year
in the meantime i just made you twelve
thousand six hundred bucks a year
and that i'm i'm a magician that way i'm
just
i'm that guy i just made up twelve
thousand dollars i just pulled it out of
the air and handed it
to you and you paid how much for this
nothing because this show is free oh my
gosh
just like that just like that 30 seconds
i think now now that savings account is
going to grow even more so a cash value
policy in its first three years has cash
value build up of zero
sometimes in the third year it'll build
up a little bit in the first two years
it's always zero and i knew his was zero
because he's in the first year
and here's the bad part some duber
that he went to high school with went
and got his license and went and sold
all his friends yep
yep and he brought his boss over to sell
him yep yep
and so he got in the door some duber
that's got in the door on relationship
and brought the big boss in who put the
arm twist on him and convinced him that
this was a good idea but he needed a
million dollars at 23 with no kids
yeah for what and that this is a great
and of course we're gonna get we're
gonna put long-term care insurance on
there too
yeah because that matters when you're
23. yeah nursing home care is a big deal
when you're 23.
jeez so don't we listen i totally
believe in long-term care insurance
never buy it with another policy do not
bundle it with anything
they're bundling it with everything out
there trying to make it work and it's
not working don't do it
you always buy your long-term care
insurance after you're 60 years old
that was going to be my question 23.
okay yeah